una selva de concreto de grúas inmóviles
y andamios vacíos esta es una ciudad
fantasma igual a tantas otras que
existen en china aquí en your own que en
el este del país debería haber un
prototipo de ciudad ideal alrededor de
este parque de atracciones un proyecto
de ever grand el gigante de la
inmobiliaria paralizado por una deuda de
300 mil millones de dólares el grupo ya
no puede pagarle a las constructoras el
resultado la obra que abarca a 130
hectáreas está detenida desde hace 2
meses y nadie o casi nadie vive aquí
chen xing se mudó a este lugar hace seis
meses vive aislado del mundo
cuando compre mi apartamento esperaba
haber escuelas tiendas el parque de
atracciones pero aquí no hay nada de eso
solo una zona desierta alrededor incluso
para poder encontrar algo de comer es
necesario utilizar el auto
sin servicios sin vecinos y con una
inversión por ahora perdida desde la
inauguración del proyecto hace 4 años el
precio del metro cuadrado ha disminuido
al menos un tercio hoy en día cuesta
alrededor de 850 dólares a pesar de todo
sienten que se considera afortunado
yo estoy bien al menos tengo un lugar
donde vivir hay muchas personas que
firmaron un contrato y pagaron un
anticipo otras que sacaron un préstamo
pero no han logrado obtener el
certificado de propiedad
al igual que james en la mayoría de los
compradores pagaron la totalidad del
precio a partir de los planos pero no
saben si algún día recibirán las llaves
de su propiedad
en septiembre en frente de la sede
central de evergrande en shenzhen una
centena de manifestantes exigían un
reembolso una escena de desespero y
rabia muy poco común en china la empresa
debe entregar más de un millón y medio
de apartamentos desde julio se habrían
entregado tan sólo 60 mil
en girona el único edificio abierto en
el parque de atracciones es esta agencia
inmobiliaria con un decorado llamativo
en el interior en el salón de
exposiciones ya nadie sueña con las
publicidades proyectadas en la inmensa
pantalla para los pocos vendedores que
aún siguen en el lugar la situación es
normal
y todavía venden apartamentos aquí
sí aunque sí que las obras están
detenidas
no no los trabajos de construcción ya se
retomaron
se dice que se retomaron
uno se retomar
algunos tienen una visión optimista del
futuro de la obra como este
inversionista estoy un poco preocupado
pero conozco los proyectos de evergrande
y estoy seguro de que encontrarán una
solución pase lo que pase pueden
solucionar sus problemas
nuestra cámara no es bienvenida
evergrande no concede entrevistas en la
prensa oficial los problemas del
promotor más endeudado del mundo apenas
se mencionan a mediados de octubre el
banco central chino tan solo hizo una
declaración pública que pretendía
tranquilizar al músico los
establecimientos financieros no están
demasiado expuestos a causas de everland
el riesgo de contagio en el resto del
sector financiero es globalmente
controlable no obstante el sector
inmobiliario representa cerca de un
tercio del pib chino la eventual quiebra
de evergrande arrastraría consigo a
miles de proveedores las constructoras
los productores de concreto de acero o
incluso las tiendas de mobiliario en
total evergrande les debería al menos
100 millones de dólares en redes
sociales varias de estas empresas
publican facturas pendientes de pago y
hablan sobre sus dificultades cuánto
tiempo más pueden mantener a las
pequeñas y medianas empresas es
desesperante
pero no paga sus facturas yo denuncié la
situación ante las autoridades pero no
hay respuestas a través de sus encargos
evergrande afirma generar 38 millones de
empleos mensuales en el terreno de la
obra en girona algunos obreros
desempleados recogen las chatarras no
han vuelto a recibir sus salarios desde
agosto
ven esas varas estamos desmontando los
andamios
si no hubiera problemas financieros
seguiríamos construyendo los edificios
todavía no sé si recibiré mi salario
al menos todavía tengo trabajo incluso
aunque no sepa cuánto me paguen por
ahora la empresa no tiene dinero que
puedo hacer al respecto
tras 30 años de urbanización frenética
financiada por la deuda evergrande está
lejos de ser un caso aislado según la
agencia de calificación standard and
poor's cerca de un tercio de las
empresas inmobiliarias chinas están al
borde de la quiebra